[Music]
all right we do have another question
here from rodney smith and it says
yes will e frame be saved
refrainly says any individual who comes
to christ will be saved
in psalm
78 i believe it is
verse
67 68
moreover he refused the tabernacle of
joseph and chose not the tribe of
ephraim but chose the tribe of judah the
mountain which he loved the tabernacle
was once in shiloh which is in the
territory of ephraim and the tabernacle
meant everything to the israelites
everything and the philistines knew that
that's why they captured the ark and
hope the ark's power would work for them
the ark was once placed at shiloh in the
territory of ephraim ephraim was not
faithful and after years of not doing
what god would have them to do even
though they're the most among the most
numerous of tribes and most influential
that's why the northern kingdom was
called ephraim the southern kingdom is
called judah ephraim is often used to
refer the entire northern kingdom made
up of ten tribes because of their
faithfulness god shifted the tabernacle
from shiloh desire
you see which is in the land of judah
and so
ephraim i any individual ephraimite who
comes to god can be saved god saves
individuals when god pronoun when noah
pronounced the curse on canaan the son
of ham eloise is clear
yes there was a curse but any individual
could have come to god when christ said
your house is left unto you desolate and
the hebrews the israelites as a nation
were rejected any individual islam could
come to god god will accept any
individual who comes to him
so yes ephraim i should be saying
danites will be saved
we may have some descendants of judas
will be saved we don't know
if you come to god
you'll be saved
so ephraimites will be saved that's my
best response
god doesn't save tribes he says
individuals who are gathered together
that's right that's right god is a
personal god god is a personal god at
all times he never changes personal god
amen amen
you